previously the connection of inner and
outer in the organic shape which is
supposed to be present to observation
was straight away transfer to the sphere
of the inorganic the determination which
produced this transfer can now be more
precisely indicated and resulting
therefrom we still have another form in
connection of this relationship namely
what is that what in the case of the
inorganic seems to offer the possibility
of such a comparison of inner and outer
in the case of the organism is
altogether absent the inorganic inner is
a simple inner which presents itself to
perception is a property that merely is
its determinant pneus is therefore
essentially magnitude and as a property
that merely is it appears indifferent
towards the outer or the various other
sensuous properties but the being for
self of the living organism does not
stand on one side in this way over
against its outer on the contrary it has
in its own self the principle of other
pneus if we define being for self is
simple self-preserving relation to self
that it's other nas's simple negativity
an organic unity is the unity of a self
identical relating to self and pure
negativity this unity is quad unity the
inwardness of the organism this is
thereby in itself universal or it is
genus but the freedom of the genus in
relation to its actual existence is
different from the freedom of specific
gravity in relation to shape the out of
the latter is a freedom that merely is
in other words specific gravity as a
particular property stands on one side
but because it is a freedom that merely
is it is also only a determinate pneus
which essentially belongs to this shape
or whereby this shape qua essential
being is something determinate the
freedom of the genus however is a
universal freedom and is indifferent
towards the shape or towards its
actuality
determinate pneus which attaches to the
being for self of the inorganic as such
falls therefore in the case of organic
being under its being for self just as
in the case of the inorganic it falls
only under the being of the latter hence
although determinate pneus in the
inorganic is at the same time present
only as a property yet it acquires the
dignity of essential being because as a
simple negative it stands over against
outer existence which is a being for
another and this simple negative is in
its ultimate simple determinate nasaan
umber the organic being however is a
singular individual which is itself pure
negativity and therefore destroys within
itself the fixed determinate pneus which
attaches to indifferent being in so far
therefore as it has within at the moment
of indifferent being and so to a number
this latter can be taken as merely a
byproduct but not as the essence of its
vitality
paragraph 291 is quite long and there's
there's a lot going on in it all of it
can be more or less represented
hopefully by what's on the board of oh I
think I see where I might have to do a
little bit more addition and as we go
along and what's what's actually
happening in this Hagel has been talking
quite a bit about the difference between
the organic and inorganic and stressing
how these are connected with each other
and how the organic is not reducible to
the inorganic to the bear being you know
and so he says that cut the connection
of inner and outer in the organic shape
previously which is supposed to be
present observation keep in mind that
that was the whole point of this entire
section this is observing reason so
observation is trying to make sense out
of the organism why because that is what
when it turned to the world and started
examining it where reason it's supposed
to be found he got caught up on them
right and they found the organic shape
to be somewhat of a puzzle somewhat of
an obstacle because of teleology because
of the entire structure of organic being
and it's trying to produce laws work so
he says it transferred the organic
there's this connection of the inner and
outer into the sphere of the inorganic
so now evil says in a fairly long-winded
way we're going to study this in a bit
more death why because we're getting
close to the end of this section so the
determination which produced this
transfer can now be more precisely
indicated so he says what in the case of
the inorganic seems to offer the
possibility of such a comparison of
inner and outer right is a in the case
of the organism altogether absent so
does that mean that something is lacking
to the organism no means the organism is
actually more complex more complicated
in a metaphysical way as well as you
know just the observation
then the inorganic is the energetic the
inner and the outer are related together
in ways that are much less problematic
so he's going to detail that first he
says the inorganic inner is a simple
inner it is it presents something to
perception you can actually perceive
what is inner now you often can't do
that directly for talking about say a
chemical compound we sort of deduce
results from the experiments that we
carry out or you know things like those
lines but we can't actually look at
quite a few things by slicing them up
and analyzing them in different ways
sixes it's a simple inner which presents
itself to perception as a property that
merely is it is determinate pneus there
is determinate pneus in the inner what
it really is inside of itself is merely
as Hagel says magnitude or number what
is this going to you know lead us to by
contrast you notice that I've got
specific gravity here the thing that
Hagel talked about in previous
paragraphs because that was kind of a
popular conception of the time and what
matters about that is that that's a
number as well and it allows things to
be contrasted to each other put into a
kind of series so it says and as a
property that mean that merely is it
appears indifferent towards the outer or
the various other sensuous properties
what it is that the perceiver is able to
take yet so he goes enemy says the being
for self of a living organism does not
stand on on one side of this way over
against its outer there is a different
kind of connection between inner and
outer in the organism then we find in
inorganic beings or in our own time we
might think since we love to model
everything on the basis of computers you
know when we when we engage in the
sort of imagined it too imaginative
projection onto organic beings of
thinking that they're really something
like algorithmic systems just very very
complex ones we're in effect doing what
Hagel is is talking about here we're
treating the organic has something
interfering so how is the organic
different he says that it being for self
of the living organism is differently on
the country it has in its own self the
principle of others so there you go
that's very hot to put up here other it
is ominous is not really there in the
internet this is a very important
distinction that Hagel is making here
it's not a distinction that he hasn't
made before right earlier on in this
this very section he did that but it's
one that he thinks we need to stress
over and over and over again this
doesn't have other nefarious in its
insofar as it is outer just as this is
being for other nests in organic things
interact with other inorganic things
which are other to them but it doesn't
have other pneus within itself as part
of what's what's driving it whereas the
organism does he have other pneus within
itself it is self other ring all the
time you might say so it says if we just
define being herself as simple
self-preserving relation self now where
is he getting that from well that was
what he's discussed much earlier in all
these other paragraphs where he's talked
about the nature of organic beating he
says that as other mrs. simple
negativity and organic unity is the
unity of the self identical relating to
self and pur- a lot of metaphysical
language there right what is he talking
about there is self negation half
within the organic being within its
inside within what it is in its being
for self part of its being for self you
could say is to not be what it is right
sounds rather surgery but remember that
for Seraph this only happens for
consciousness whereas this is happening
for anything living for cable so he goes
and he says this human de is quiet unity
the inwardness of the organism that was
going to make an important step here
what do we have as this this in turn s
it is something universal what is
universal to the organism well Hagel is
going to talk here about the genus about
the kind of thing that it is she
starting he's starting on a path where
he's going to talk about Jesus
individual and species as something in
between the two of them so this is very
important to keep in mind here that the
primary connection is going to be
between genus and individual genus being
conceived as something that is inner and
an individual as you might say it's
external ization so he goes on he says
we've got the genus the freedom of the
genus in relation to its actual
existence is different from the freedom
of specific gravity in relation shape in
fact when Hagel saying is this is not
particularly helpful for understanding
the living organism or indeed the genus
that the living organism belongs to what
it is it makes it the kind of organism
that it is you can't have individuals
without having some script genus right
because it's complicated right so we
were tempted to use this sort of
reconstruction in previous paragraphs
modeled after what's
and in here in inorganic being to make
sense of the organism and Hagel is
saying to us no that's not the way that
we want to go instead we have a genus
and the genus exerts a certain kind of
freedom he says the freedom of the
specific remedy has is one that merely
is in other words specific gravity he
says is a particular property stands on
one side right it's sort of in different
shape that was part of the problem there
seemed to be some arbitrariness here
that doesn't get us the relationship of
expression so because it is a freedom
that merely it is it is also only a
determinate pneus which essentially
belongs to this shape or whereby this
shape as essential day of something
determine so if we're getting away from
that and we're talking about the freedom
of the genus he says the freedom of the
genus is a universal freedom and is
indifferent towards this shape or
towards its actuality there is a certain
I don't want to say indeterminate us
because we're talking about
determination right now what is it for
something to be a crayfish what is it
for something to be a horse what is it
for something to be a microbe that you
know attaches itself to a particular
type of host tissue what is it for
something to be an elephant right all of
these are questions that were asking
about the genus and the genus itself you
know we were tempted to reduce it just
to a bunch of qualities or
classifications but really each one of
them insofar as it is a genus of a
living type of being possesses an
internal unity a coherence a
universality a relationship to self as
well as an externalization in
individuals that's when Hagel is calling
here the freedom of the genus so he says
there's terminus which attaches to the
being for self of the of the inorganic
that such falls therefore in the case of
organically under its being for self
just as in the case of
inorganic it falls only under the being
of ladder yes although in terminus in
inorganic is at the same time present
only as a property it acquires the
dignity of the sexual being because as a
simple negative it stands over against
outer existence which is being poor and
up what's going on here is much much
more complicated not only in terms of
structure but in terms of the very meta
physics involved so he goes on and he
says of the organic being is a singular
in the individual which is itself pure
negativity how does it peer negativity
that's what we're going to have to
examine so he says it destroys what
within itself the fixed determinant
pneus which attaches to indifferent be
the external of say it crystal or a book
or a piece of truck or a piece of
clothing says insofar as it has within
itself the moment of indifferent being
enough number this latter can be taken
merely as a by-product but not as the
essence of its vitality so where should
we look them for the essence of the
vitality the liveliness T the ability to
respond to external circumstances to
modify itself to continue on well that's
a question that we're going to have to
answer as we move through the next
paragraphs
but now through pure negativity the
principle of the process does not fall
outside of the organism which the air
for does not have it in its essence as a
determinant pneus the single individual
being itself intrinsically Universal yet
in the organism the moments of this pure
individual are not developed and actual
as moments which are themselves abstract
or universal on the contrary this their
expression appears outside of that
universality which falls back into the
inwardness of the organism and between
the actual existence or shape that is
the self developing individual and the
organic and universal or the genus there
comes the determinant it Universal the
species the concrete existence attained
by the negativity of the universal or
the genus is only the developed movement
of a process which runs its course in
the parts of the inert existence of the
shape if the genus as a quiescent
unitary being had within it the
differentiated parts and if to it's
simple negativity as such were at the
same time a movement which ran through
parts which were equally simple and
immediately universal in themselves
parts which here were actual in such
moments then the organic genus would be
consciousness but as it is the simple
determinant is quad a terminus of the
species is present in the genus and a
non spiritual manner actuality starts
from the genus or what enters into
actual existence is not the genus is
such that is in general not the thought
of it the genus as an actual organism is
merely represented by a surrogate by
number this latter number seems to mark
the transition from the genus into the
individual structured shape and to
provide observation with the two
necessary aspects of the latter one is a
simple determinate pneus and the other
as a shape whose manifold nature is
fully developed this number however
really indicates the indifference and
freedom of the universal and the
individual in relation to one another
the genus puts the individual at the
mercy of the non-essential quantitative
difference but the individual itself
quad living individual equally shows
itself to be free true universality as
we have defined it is here
only in inner essence as determinants
pneus of the species it is a it is a
formal universality and over against
this the true universality takes it
stand on the side of the single
individual which is thereby a living
individual and in virtue of its inner
being takes no account of its
determinants pneus as species but this
individual is not at the same time a
universal individual that is one in
which the universality would have an
outer actual existence as well the
universal individual falls outside of
the living organism there's a universal
individual however is immediately the
individual of a natural of natural
structured shapes is not consciousness
itself its existence as a single organic
living individual must not fall outside
of that if it is to be consciousness
paragraph 292 is one of those
problematic paragraphs in which Hagel is
going to narrate for us what
consciousness is supposed to be
observing as it works through its
conceptions about the nature of organic
being and all these things that we've
been studying up until this point but it
doesn't attain a real resolution instead
what ends up happening is all of the
possible relations or resolutions end up
getting problematized further he's
bringing us ultimately to a crux and
notice what I've done here no longer is
inner and outer identifiable you know
strictly we had something like the genus
or the individual we have the inner you
know ultimately being expressed in the
outer and these hopefully but now
intersecting it we have this this other
axis you might say that Hagel is talking
about in terms of the the genus which is
a certain kind of universal the gods
woman right in the individual which is
also in a certain respect universal but
all that Universal is going to get sort
of lost and it takes on determinate
shape or shapes and then in between we
have what he's calling and he's
introducing another point to this the
determinate universal or the species the
art so how is this going to play itself
out he says the principle the process
doesn't fall outside of the organism
through this pure negativity so it
doesn't have in its essence as a
determinant is the single individual
being itself intrinsically reversal
right but in the organism the moments of
this pure individual are not developed
an actual as moments which are
themselves abstract or universal in a
certain respect does it make sense to
talk about a single determinate
individual of a genus of a species of
living
thing as being abstract as being
Universal in that sense what we see here
is Hagel is a zach is playing with the
sense of universal which doesn't always
mean the same thing at every
circumstance so he goes on bases on the
contrary this their expression appears
outside of the universality the
universality says falls back into the
interior the inner right the inwardness
of the organism and between the actual
existence are shaped that is the self
developing individual and the organic
Universal or the genus there comes the
determinate universal the species the
concrete existence obtained by the
negativity of the universal to the genus
right here's the the genus is only the
developed movement of a process which
runs its course in the parts of the
inert existence of the shape so he says
now he talks about the genus as being a
quiescent unitary being restful
quiescent Ruby go right the genus
doesn't actually do anything like you
know let's just imagine bunny rabbits
fur for a moment right the genus of
bunny rabbit doesn't go out there and
nibble on grass and look around
trepidatious Lee at Hawks or dogs and
burrow into the dirt and copulate and
make all sorts of new bunny rabbits
although in a certain sense it does
right because all rabbits are presumably
doing that sort of thing not all of them
are cramps of them you know miss the
mark in that respect but it's not it's
not engaging in that sort of activity or
action which is characteristic of the
type of thing that hurts talking about
right so he goes out
says the genus if the genes can within
of the differentiated parts and if to
its simple negativity we're at the same
time of movement which ran through parts
which were equally simple and
immediately universal themselves Hertz
which here were actuals moments then the
organic genus would be consciousness now
that's kind of an interesting departure
isn't them the genus itself doesn't have
any consciousness as genus genus is what
we are conscious of and we can say that
insofar as any particular type of being
apprehends itself as being that type of
being in hannah's consciousness of
itself as being a type bit what would I
am eating by this you know when we think
for example about elephants recognizing
each other as elephants and
communicating with each other or even
the fact that elephants as we now know
are intelligent enough to have some sort
of orientation towards their own debt
that means something there is a kind of
consciousness going on there that's not
happening on the part of the genus
itself right because the genus is
abstract the geniuses you might say an
idea it's not something that happens
that X journalized reality that allows
it to be in relation to the world
indeterminate shapes that blend into
each other from moment to moment to
moment so it was how many says as it is
the simple determinate pneus quad a
terminus of the species is present to
the genus in a non spiritual manner and
on questia it's not something that that
has consciousness it's something we can
observe certain lady right so he says
actuality starts from the genus or what
enters into actual existence is not the
genus of such
that is in general not the thought of it
the genus is an actual organism is
merely represented by surrogate and now
we see once again Hagel going back to
this you know notion that we could like
give some sort of number for genus but
we see that this is a failed approach
right you're not going to get any real
mileage out of the signing some sort of
number like specific gravity or whatever
you like you know the maze will just
come up with a an ordering system that
randomly assigns not first two
particular caves of being and that would
be just as just as handy women indian so
he says this lab air seems to mark the
transition from the genus into the
individual structure chief seems stupid
it actually dozens and the problem is it
doesn't provide observation with what it
is it's looking for he says the number
really indicates the indifference and
the freedom of the universal and the
individual in relation to each other the
genus puts the individual at the mercy
of the non-essential quantitative
difference the individual in order to
fit into them now the individual and as
the individual really exists could it
could care less about whatever number
reason once to assign to it you know the
bunny rabbit hopping around doesn't
really care we decided to fire an eight
or a ten whatever right and it's not
like reality itself is doing so it's us
human beings yeah the observing reason
who are trying to do that but once we
enter into that scheme and we start
engaging in this spot process involved
with numbers there's a disconnect here
right and as this disconnect loses any
hold on on this the species so he says
the the genus puts the individual at the
mercy of the non-essential quantitative
difference the individual itself equally
shows itself to be free that is
unconstrained that is able to sort of
thumb its little bunny nose
the universal says that it ought to do
and we see this occurring right even if
we don't do it in terms of quanta
quantity and we do it in terms of
quality the conception of the genius
that we have that we're using the
thought right of the thing often um you
know the constraints that seem to be
imposed on it the actual living
organisms the individual beings do quite
otherwise they you know we don't even
have to like appeal to necessarily
something like evolution to talk about
that that has to do with you know entire
species and random differences in
reproduction we can just talk in terms
of you know we have our conception of
what dog is and then there's dogs that
don't actually conform to it they
surprise us they go beyond the idea that
we have coming to us from from the genus
so he says true universality is here
only as an interestin SAT the
determinate pneus of the species it is a
formal universality over against this
the true universality takes it stand on
the side of the single individual which
is the everybody living individual and
in virtue of its interviewing takes no
account of its determinate us as a
species but he says this individual is
not at the same time a universal
individual we could say that any
individual thing wants to be what it is
and it wants to be to some degree
unconstrained by the universal that it
should fall into it wants to be its own
Universal it wants to be you might say
tsui generous as we say now the many
Gina's not of any species but that's not
really possible isn't the determinant
pedic is a being of a particular type
and so it cannot be a universal
individual he says one in which the
universality would have our actual
existence as well this universal
individual falls outside
the the living organism what does that
mean well this is not the same thing as
this this you might say expresses that
and now we get something light inner and
outer right but that's not the same
thing as being it so he goes na says
this Universal individual however is
immediately the individual of natural
structure chains is not consciousness
itself its existence as a single organic
living individual must not fall outside
of it if it is to be consciousness what
does then tell us here we're dealing
with something that is less a solution
or a resolution and more the beginnings
of a problem where does consciousness
fit in with this that's something that
we want to know in part because
observing reason is supposed to be
observing itself in the world what in
its finding in the world is what it is
brought to the world so how is this
going to work we have to look at the
next paragraph to see that
consequently we have a syllogism in
which one extreme is the universal life
as a universal or as genus the other
extreme however being the same universal
as a single individual or as a universal
individual but the middle term is
composed of both the first seems to fit
itself into it as a determinate
universality or as species the other
however is individuality proper or as a
single individual and since this
syllogism pertains wholly to the aspect
of the structured shape it equally
embraces within its scope what is
distinguished as inorganic nature
in paragraph 2 93 we see angle once
again using his language and conceptual
framework of syllogism in finding the
middle term remember the middle term or
the mediating term is what connects the
two extremes what allows them to be
brought into a connection with each
other and this is a short paragraph
there's not a lot going on here other
than sort of just setting this out he
tells us that we have two extremes on
the one side we have universal life
which can be understood as the universal
or the genus right the universal of a
certain sort on the other side however
we have the universal as well right so
the universal has been can't split the
universal as individual or the single
individual the thing that actually lives
right we have the the type and we have
the instance the reality we have the the
idea and we have the thing but this is
the Earthies are both self related and
they both have other pneus within them
and I related to each other in others so
how do we bring these together Hagel
says that we have a middle term and
instead of just saying okay the middle
term he is X notice what he says he
tells us that the middle term itself is
kind of split or it has two sides
binding it together right so we might
say that this is all the middle term but
the middle term insofar as it presents
its face to the other side it looks
different so on the side closest to
universal logically of the species on
this side we have individuality as
something different than being a single
individual you might say well what is
what is that well think about the
general case of being an individual
that's different than actually being
this particular individual so he says
that since the syllogism
chains holding to the aspect of the
structured shape it equally embraces
within its scope what is distinguished
as inorganic nature this applies not
only to organic nature but also
encompasses inorganic nature which
really doesn't doesn't you know this is
more complicated in many respects in
terms of universality then inorganic
nature provides us with but that's
because organic nature you know we often
think of it is a little bit of a
digression that's worth reflecting on
here we often think of life as something
that sort of extra it's added on to
inorganic nature that emerges out of it
perhaps or you know it's an extra
property Hagel doesn't see things that
way and this in a certain respect
represents a more ancient view I would
say that says that the higher is really
the origin of the lower not the other
way around that's because for Hegel the
higher is always been in there working
itself through just not being recognized
so you know you could have it looking
like it's emergent we'll even though it
is really so we're only is so within a
certain perspective but here's the
syllogism as Hagel lays it out in a
schematic form this is the mediating
term and now in the paragraphs to come
we're going to explore that a little bit
further and bring this section to a
close